Film Courage: I know you’re writing your
autobiography So I’m going to steal a question
I heard on C-Span.
I just finished watching THE POST movie and
they interviewed Katharine Graham years ago
and she wrote a tell-all book about THE POST
and her family and the troubles with her husband
and his depression (things like that).
And the interviewer said t her “Why do you
want people to know this?”
She said “Good question.
I started [writing] and I was only going to
tell one thing and I just kept going.
I couldn’t stop.”
Bill Duke, Actor/Filmmaker/Author: I’m writing
this book
for all the losers in the world.
For all the people who have been told you
cannot do it, you’re a loser, you’re too
stupid, you’re too ugly, you’re too dumb
or too black.
You’re too whatever.
You’re never going to make it.
I’ve been called all those things
and worse.
I’m writing this book because I want children
who are going through similar things to never
give up on themselves.
If I can get through it so can you.
Never…never…whether you are five or 100,
never give up.
It’s never too late.
You determine your reality.
Are there forces that help shape the context
around you?
Of course there are.
I mean…but what is your responsibility?
Because the boogeyman is bigger than you,
you don’t fight back?
You don’t do nothing?
You don’t bite his toe?
You just talk about the size of the boogeyman,
how long he’s been on your neck?
The color of the boogeyman, the boogeyman
system, how can I say?
The odor of his breath?
You can describe every aspect of the boogeyman
for the rest of your damn life or you can
bite his toe.
Now you ain’t going to l him if you bite
his toe, but toe’s are sensitive.
There’s going to be some movement.
All you need is a little bit…a little bit…but
you’re not going to bite?
That’s your definition of your possibilities
in life.
“I can’t bite because the boogeyman is
so big and I’m so weak…goodbye.”
Sorry.
Not me.
Never.
You’ve got to have
my guess a couple of, they better
hit something that is vital because they can
remove them and I’m coming back.
Never give up.
Never.
And as my family used to say to the people
who try to stop you and put you down, there
is only one phrase that they deserve and that
is this: “I ain’t as dumb as you look.
I ain’t as damn dumb as you look.
We can keep talking but I want you to know
something, I ain’t as dumb as you look.”
You know it’s interesting, once they see
that they know you are not playing checkers
in a chess game.
You are playing chess.
As long as we’re both playing chess, let’s
play.
I got some damn moves too.
Let’s just play.
Don’t tell me how good a checker player
I am.
That’s how I feel.